'S PILLOW ONCE AGAIN THE LOCAL
ON A BENDER ASKING DRAKE SCHOOL
KIDS ABOUT THEIR GENDER.
THEY RECEIVED A HEALTH SURVEY
THAT ASKED THEM TO DEFINE THEIR
SEXUALITY.
YOU'RE MY DOCTOR ASKED ME THAT
ALL THE TIME.
WHERE THING IS HE'S A
PODIATRIST.
[LAUGHTER]
KIDS AS YOUNG AS 11, WERE ASKED
WHETHER THEY FEEL LGBTQ OR
ANYTHING ELSE?
BUT HERE'S THE KICKER THEY GOT
12 GENDER OPTIONS TO CHOOSE
FROM.
IN CLOSING SUCH INCIDENTS AS TO
SPIRIT, A GENDER, DEMI, ENDEMIC
GIRL.
BUT NO DEMI MOORE?
I'VE BEEN IDENTIFYING AS HOW TO
USE THE LADIES ROOM THE
PLANET FITNESS.
SATELLITE AUTOGRAPHS.
ACTUALLY, I'M TRY BINARY IF I
CAN BUY IT I'LL TRY.
OREGON STATE AUTHORITIES SAY
THAT THE SURVEY IS VOLUNTARY AND
ANONYMOUS.
VOLUNTARY AND ANONYMOUS, BUT IF
IT HURTS FOR GLORY HOLES --
[LAUGHTER]
YEAH
I WENT THERE, I MEAN I WENT TO
THE JOKE.
AND I GUESS THE CHOICE TO BE
GROOMED IS UP TO THE KIDS.
AT WILL CREDIT TO HIS WEBSITE IS
PART OF A NEW PLANT TO "ENSURE
THAT ALL YOU HISTORIC SUCCESSFUL
LEARNERS" BECAUSE NOTHING MAKES
THEM MORE EXCITED TO LEARN BY
BEING TOLD BY BEARCATS.
MANY A OUTRAGE WHICH THEY'VE
REPORTEDLY CONDUCTED IN THE PAST
WITHOUT TELLING MOM AND DAD.
BUT YES IT'S ANONYMOUS BUT IT
SEEMS THAT THE KIDS WHAT PARENTS
WANT THEM IN THE DARK.
AND WHAT KIND OF ADULT STRANGER
WITH A DEBT FOR THAT?
BUT I REMEMBER WHEN THE ONLY
ONES HIDING STUFF AND PARENTS
WERE ACTUALLY STUDENTS.
I STILL REMEMBER WHERE I USED TO
HIDE THOSE HUSTLERS.
STEVE AND VIC THOSE GUYS WERE
BARELY LAUGHS.
ANY BECAUSE I KEPT THEM IN THE
BARREL.
AND THEN THEY CRIED MORE THAN
LOFT.
>> JUST ADMIT YOU HAD
MAGAZINES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> DON'T TRY TO COVERING ALL
UP BECAUSE IT WAS HOSTAGE.
>> BETWEEN THE MATTRESS THIS
WAY KEPT IN.
HOTEL, WHERE THE ADULTS, WHAT
HAPPENED TO LIKE TEACHERS, AND
DOCTORS, AND LEADERS, THIS
POISON IS GARBAGE KIND OF
BASICALLY SPEWING TO OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM?
AND NOBODY'S STOPPING IT.
THERE'S NOT ONE PERSON GOING NO,
THIS IS CRAZY.
IT FREAKS ME OUT.
>> AT THIS POINT, THERE MORE
GENDERS, THEN THERE IS
BASKIN-ROBBINS HAS FLAVORS OF
ICE CREAM.
OKAY, SO BEFORE THEY ASSIGNED ME
A GENDER, I JUST DECIDED TO PICK
ON MY OWN GENDER.
SO I CHOSE ASTRO GENDER.
THIS IS A REAL GENDER, 72 LIST,
BUBBLE BATH.
SO ASTRO GENDER SOMEONE WHO
IDENTIFIES WITH OUTER SPACE.
AND I CHOSE THIS BECAUSE I NEED
TO GET THE HILL OFF THIS PLANET.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHTER]
>> SO, WE CALL THIS, I CALL
THIS THE GROOMING BILL BECAUSE
IT IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS.
BUT I REPRESENT HOTEL AND
THEY'RE ALL ABOUT SUPPORTING --
PEOPLE ARE MOVING AND ANGELS,
BUT WE WANT TO START PUSHING
PEOPLE TO HOMESCHOOLING, AND
THIS BE DUE.
AND I THINK THIS BILL, IT IS A
HUGE RED ALERT AND SAFE KNOW
THAT PEOPLE NEED TO START
HOMESCHOOLING.
>> DEFINITELY, THAT, AGAIN,
THIS FALLS INTO THE CONCEPT OF
AGE APPROPRIATENESS.
IT'S LIKE EVEN IF I SAID --
QUESTIONNAIRE IS FINE, BUT WHY
IS IT YOU HAVE AGAINST THE IDEA
OR THE CONCEPT OF AGE
APPROPRIATENESS.
TO BE ABLE TO SAY, THIS IS NOT
FOR KID.
HE SUPPOSED BE RACIST OR BAKE IT
YOU SAY THAT?
>> IN THE SIXTH GRADE I
WOULD'VE NOT KNOW WHAT ANY OF
THE STUFF WAS, I WAS SUPER
INNOCENT THOUGH, REMEMBER BEFORE
SCHOOL ONE DAY, I BEND MY NECK
WITH A CURLING IRON.
AND THEN AT SCHOOL EVERYONE WAS
LIKE IS THAT A HICKEY?
AND I DID NOT KNOW WHAT THAT
WAS.
SO I JUST SAID YES.
AND THEN I FOUND OUT WHAT IT
WAS -- AND I SAID NO.
THEN I WAS LIKE OH THAT SOUNDS
COOL.
BUT, OF ALL THE LANGUAGE IN THIS
WHOLE SITUATION THAT MAKES ME
MAD, THE THING THAT MAKES ME THE
MOST MAD IS, GOVERNMENT FUNDED?
BECAUSE WE SHOULD CALL IT WHAT
IT ACTUALLY IS WHICH IS
TAXPAYER-FUNDED, BECAUSE, YOU GO
TO PRISON IF YOU DON'T PAY YOUR
TAXES, BUT THEN THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE SPENDING OUR MONEY ON.
>> EXACTLY.
I WOULD PREFER TO GO TO PRISON
RATHER THAN HAVE MY KIDS BEING
TAUGHT THIS.
IT'S DISGUSTING CURRENTLY.
HERE ABOUT TO POP OUT A BABY?
I AM -- RIGHT.
RIGHT NOW.
-- I CAN DO IT.
SO, I THINK, THIS IS WHY SEVERAL
COUNTIES IN OREGON, HAVE
LITERALLY VOTED TO SECEDE FROM
THE STATE.
AND BECOME A PART OF IDAHO, AND
I THINK THAT IT WILL JUST NEED
TO TAKE A MINUTE THIS POINT OF
THE PUBLIC SERVICE THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ABOUT HOW WILD
THIS TREND IS.
WORLD BOATS ARE SO INTERESTED IN
TALKING TO KIDS ABOUT NOW, AND
WHEN PEOPLE QUESTION THEN, THEY
CLAIM THE MORAL HIGH GROUND.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO -- IF
YOU ARE INTERESTED TO TALK UNTIL
11-YEAR-OLDS ABOUT THEIR
SEXUAL PREFERENCES, THERE IS
REALLY SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOU.
AND SOME OF THESE ARE SO
WIDOWED, TO SPIRIT IS A TERM
THAT WAS CREATED IN THE 1990s,
SO IS RELATIVELY NEW.
AT THE INDIGENOUS LGBTQ
GATHERING IN WINNIPEG.
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
>> ELLE DUNCAN IN WINNIPEG.
WINNIPEG.
>> NA DESCRIBES NATIVE PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITIES WILL FULFILL
A TRADITION TRADITION OF THEIR
GENDER.
>> AN 11-YEAR-OLD THE SPECIFIC
AND I WILL NOT?
>> THEY TURN SEX EDUCATION
INTO EDUCATION.
OR JUST A HOBBY.
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO
KIDS ABOUT THEIR -- YOU ARE
INSANE.
EXCUSE ME.
YOU KNOW -- TY HARRIS, CHILDREN
HAVE ENOUGH HIRES IN THE MAY
PROBLEMS THAT -- AND THESE
PEOPLE.
BE TERRIFIED OF YOU?
MEMORANDA TO TALK TO HIS KIDS
ABOUT --
>> WHAT I DO NOT HAVE THAT
ISSUE BECAUSE, MOST -- I'M DOWN
TO ONE.
ALL MY KIDS ARE HOMESCHOOLED.
I PUT THEM ALL OUT.
NOW PLAYING WITH THAT STUFF.
NUMBER TWO, I DO NOT SEE THE
DIFFERENCE, THEY USED TO BE A TV
SHOW ON CAN'T CATCH A PREDATOR.
IT WILL BE THE THING, A GROWN
MAN TALKING TO A 15-YEAR-OLD
ABOUT.
THAT WAS DESPICABLE, DEPLORABLE,
HE WAS A LISTED, THE POLICE
DRAGGED THEM OUT, NOW THAT GUY
TO COME TO SCHOOL AND TALK TO
EVERYONE.
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE.
ABSOLUTELY NO DIFFERENCE.
MY 11-YEAR-OLD, AND I'M AN
EXPERT BECAUSE I HAVE
311-YEAR-OLDS.
ALL DIFFERENT DIVERSITIES, SO
YOU KNOW I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
INTERNATIONAL -- WHEN I'M
DEALING WITH MY -- EAT >> YOUR
UNITED NATIONS OF DAD.
>> AND ACROSS THE BOARD, HAVE
ENOUGH TIME REMEMBERING THE
CHOICE THEY HAVE TO DO LET ALONE
THE GENDERS.
DOING WHAT WAS CLEVER ENOUGH IS
THE 8-YEAR-OLD, WHO WOULD SAY
ANY OF THOSE THINGS TO GET ONTO
STUFF.
>> HOW DID I TO BED -- AND HE
SAY NO I DON'T IDENTIFY WITH
CLOCKS.
AND SHE'S CLEVER.
WHERE THE 11 EUROS WILL SAY I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF ANY OF THESE
CANDIES.
>> HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT THESE CANDIES ARE GOOD OR
BAD?
MY CHILDREN ARE INNOCENT AND
HOMESCHOOLED.
IN THE-YEAR-OLDS WATCH CLOSING.
BUT I WOULD NOT ALLOW A STRANGER
TO TALK TO MY CHILDREN ABOUT THE
WEATHER, LET ALONE -- IF YOU
COME UP TO MY CHILD, BE LIKE
HELLO, YOU BE GREETED WHEN YOU
NEED I'M RIGHT HERE?
>> BECAUSE IT BLOWS MY MIND.
I MAY NOT GO UP IN THE 70s --
AND PEOPLE -- IF THE TEACHER DID
THIS THEY WOULD BE DISAPPEARED.
IT'S JUST SO BIZARRE.
>> IT JUST GOES BACK TO THE
SMALL PERCENTAGE PRESENTED TO BE
LARGER THAN WHAT IT IS.
IN A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF RIGHT
NOW HIDING BEHIND AGAIN --
FEMININITY, AND EDUCATION, BUT
AT THE SAME THING IF IT WAS A
DAINTY OPENING.
BUT IT WASN'T DIRTY OLD MAN WHO
DOES ON